this is the roadster
the first car tesla ever released in
2008 and it was developed and produced
in california
[Music]
fast forward 13 years to today and you
can find teslas on the road around the
world
i think we're close to establishing a
channel
in russia but tesla isn't just selling
cars abroad
it's also setting up factories around
the world the key for
tesla's global expansion is going to be
expanding
manufacturing capacity quickly tesla's
push comes at a time when the stakes of
going global are big
as the ev market will surge 775
to about 35 million cars by 2030 and
that can come with pitfalls
after a spate of bad publicity in china
tesla's sales took a hit in april
and auto analysts aren't sure if the
company can keep growing as fast in one
of its biggest markets
what tesla's trying to do is really
drive home that
first mover advantage make sure it
retains that number one spot
we analyzed three key speeches by musk
in the past year to understand how tesla
plans to put more of its vehicles on the
road all over the world
first we go to moscow in may musk gave a
speech via video conference to hundreds
of students and tech entrepreneurs at a
forum sponsored by the russian
government
he spoke about a wide range of topics
from politics and religion to outer
space
we need to establish a self-sustaining
base on the moon
and on mars but what really made
headlines was when he hinted at future
plans for a new factory
the suggestion came as a surprise
because tesla hasn't sold many cars in
russia
there are around 700 vehicles on the
roads there
but russia could fit a template tesla
has used before to open factories where
it sees market potential
there are two big electric vehicle
markets in the world
china and europe tesla's already in
china and now it's
opening a plant in europe that new plant
is near berlin an auto analyst expected
to open in early 2022.
it's planning to produce half a million
cars a year and this would allow tesla
to directly sell its vehicles to
european countries
instead of importing them from china and
the us as it currently does
with the three biggest markets covered
auto analysts have been divided over
where musk will set up shop next
some say he should double down on the
so-called brick countries
brazil russia india and china the big
automakers are in brazil because that's
a big market
it's probably a good guess that tesla's
looking at that
and of course one of them is the
untapped market of russia which grew by
95
last year i think there's a lot of
talent and energy in russia
building factories in new countries is a
major logistical challenge especially
with a hands-on
ceo like elon musk i think what for
tesla right now is the gig of berlin so
he's in berlin
spent a fair bit of time in berlin
working on that in a one-on-one video
call with the wall street journal's
editor-in-chief in december last year
musk explained how he liked working
closely with his engineers
when i have spent too much time in a
conference room that's generally when
things have gone awry
and when i go and spend time on the
factory floor really using the
the cars that's where things have gone
gone better
musk says being on the factory floor is
essential to creating good products
especially because his company builds
many parts like the battery packs and
develops much of the software in-house
but this makes it difficult for tesla to
ramp up production compared with
traditional automakers that are moving
into evs
it doesn't have the factories it doesn't
have the distribution networks on the
ground
existing manufacturers like volkswagen
toyota gm
they already have a global manufacturing
footprint
and they already have global
distribution networks so
what they're doing is converting
existing plants
into electric vehicle plants
plus building a factory from scratch can
cost billions of dollars
and if the company fails to scale
quickly enough before other evs flood
the market
a solution may be to think more like a
traditional automaker
it may be able to do this by building
its own factories
or it may one day have to rely on
contract manufacturers like foxconn
which builds for apple and is now
getting into
electric vehicles working in new markets
also means navigating different
regulatory environments
and in the u.s musk has been known to
collide with regulators
the best thing that government can do is
just get out of the way it's a contrast
to his public persona in china
i'm very confident that the future in
china is going to be great
and that china is headed towards being
the biggest economy in the world
in march musk sat down for an interview
with china's national television channel
to talk about the country's economic
plan
what attracts me most about china's
five-year plan is the
tremendous commitment to a low-carbon
economy and ultimately to a sustainable
energy economy
[Music]
that says a lot about how he's been
willing to change his approach
when working in china i really want to
thank the government officials that have
been really helpful
conflict with the authorities really
doesn't work here at all he obviously
knows alan has
has really done everything he can to
praise
officials to praise the chinese system
tesla has taken a conciliatory approach
when challenged
for instance at the shanghai auto show
in april a woman climbed on top of a
tesla vehicle to shout allegations about
faulty brakes
the woman's claims couldn't be verified
independently but complaints about tesla
spread across the chinese internet
the company publicly apologized and
pledged to set up a customer
satisfaction unit
a few months later tessa complied with
chinese regulators to address safety
issues with a software upgrade in more
than 285 000 vehicles
musk has been less contentious with
chinese officials and that has played a
part in tesla's success there
for example the factory in shanghai was
built in 10 months
just compare that with this plant in
berlin as far back as 2015 musk has
courted german officials
even the country's head of state angela
merkel but the plant is still facing a
six-month delay
some industry watchers say it was caused
by tesla's own lack of coordination
given the company had benefited from
legislation that helped to fast-track
construction
musk has said german bureaucracy and
activist environmental concerns over
water usage and the plant's impact on
local wildlife
or why the project is behind he tweeted
that the factory wouldn't use as much
water
and that trees in the area were
originally planted to be turned into
cardboard
the delay at the berlin plan shows how
even a superstar ceo
can't get around german approval
processes it's still
organized kind of like a startup with a
charismatic leader
who basically controls everything from
the top down which makes it very hard
for
a company to deal with local regulatory
issues it needs
strong management on the ground which it
doesn't really have here
maybe it needs a ceo and a real board
that could in the long run hinder
tesla on its path to growth so if elon
musk wants to convert tesla into a truly
global player
the billionaire ceo may have to buckle
up and prepare for a bumpy ride
[Music]